got a question just about Egypt now I
know I know you you're a historian um
how how's your what are your thoughts
about like Egypt your your mom and dad
obviously grew up there they moved to to
the US like what's the been the progress
of Egypt in let's say the last I don't
know you know since the 60s since you
know yeah well that that goes back to
what you were saying you know with
turkey um it's interesting most people
don't realize when you look at these
nations Egypt Etc and you see radical
Muslims and you know the women in hijab
Etc it's ironic because if you go back
50 years there were it was like looking
at Europe you never saw that it wasn't
just in um Iran even in Egypt you know
you know you rarely saw women in hijabs
or the men with the you know the Islamic
copy kind of look what what dates are
you talking about like what decades
1950s and 60s even before that oh really
yes and a lot of it is in large me
measure due to the European colonial era
okay with the European colonial era of
of North Africa and Asia and Islamic
Nations they actually become became
westernized they were Western looking
yes um not just physically Western they
were yeah and they were
happy Islam was actually seen if you
read historic as I did books written by
Oxford Dawns in the 1960s and70s Islam
was dead it was kind of like it was in
Egypt particularly in all everywhere and
in Egypt wow so actually the comeback it
was the surprise of Islam and he really
you know it was it was shot off in 1979
with the Iranian Revolution yes yes um
but then it became everywhere A lot of
it also is from Saudi Arabia because of
the oil yes they spend they disseminate
so much radical literature yes you know
they call them wahabis but all that
means is they're just literalist purist
Muslims radicals right right um so they
play a big measure in the dissemination
of that sort of literature and they
support it so how did Egypt start to get
I guess colonized by Muslims yeah yeah
Egypt's big thing which actually
impacted much of the Muslim world is the
Muslim Brotherhood was born in Egypt
right around 1928
um thean as they're known and you know
out of them branched out almost every
other even terrorist organizations care
if you guys have heard of here they're a
branch of the Muslim Brotherhood y did
USA fund Muslim Brotherhood oh yeah
during the Obama and Clinton era they
were their allies you know they just uh
Brotherhood for a time you know they had
one of their men was the president of
Egypt Mory Muhammad Mory okay um and
this was during the Obama era they were
close allies wow and this is this is I
assume a sort like the strategy was like
they were trying to destabilize yeah
this was the you know the Arab Spring
yes that quickly turned into a winter
right um and it took different guises
some one was that the Muslim Brotherhood
won supposedly through a fair and free
election and uh others were the wars we
had one of those in 2020 I
know and then others were the you know
the the Freedom Fighters and who turned
out to be Isis that we were supporting
all along figh started in the 70s and
then yeah exactly that goes way back you
know um we were the the muah against the
USSR so was there some major change then
in foreign policy where I mean if you go
from colon sort of a colonization kind
of mindset that is like we we know that
the best thing for the Middle East is
westernization broadly Christendom
Christianity um a and then but at some
point did did that stop
or did something else Revolution
something else overtake it so I have a
theory which I laid out in one in my
older book crucified again which is
basically um like the golden okay so
that book is about persecution of
Christians and I use that as a litmus
test in so to to see how radical a
Muslim Society is obviously the more
Christians are persecuted the more
radical yes and with the um with the
Advent of the colonial era in Egypt I
actually look at that a lot so they
brought a lot of rule and all of a
sudden the appeal of ISL you have to
understand from the beginning unlike
Christianity was it it helped you out if
you become Muslim you're going to get
richer you're going to get more women
you're going to get more wives yes
you're going to be on the winning team
okay because that's how it grew when
Muhammad was a itinerary preacher and he
had like no followers for a decade yeah
and then once he started plundering and
becoming successful and a powerful
warlord that's when they started joining
the bandwagon yes in the Arab Conquest
so really it was always understood
amongst Muslim Islam is makes you
prosperous in the now
with the colonial era all of a sudden
Muslims started noticing oh now we're
being ruled by the these infidels and
they're bringing so much good stuff into
the world we have medicine we have
technology we have education so Islam
that's what I was saying it started sort
of falling and backsliding it was no
longer it was seen as the what ignorant
people do the low lives kind of um but I
my theory is that in as much as the West
started to withdraw not not don't mean
militarily or even physically but
culturally culturally with and Abate its
ownit and start poo pooing its own
culture and start praising Islam Muslims
started going back to Islam and I
believe that is the that's how we went
from 1950 and 60 and before and Muslims
were actually very Westward looking to
actually falling back into Islam wow you
are the LIE of the world right you if
you lose your salt guess what there's no
Savor anywhere else right so that's
exactly that's amazing so that would
line up then right with I mean 60s and
70s here the states you've got all this
sort of repudiation of Christian root
and that's the birth of radicalization
there and going back like going back to
like Eastern philosophy and Eastern
religion and Islam and you're and you're
saying that kind of that virus took hold
from from
westerners proudly telling Muslims this
is how we are and you should be like us
and Them emulating westerners started
condemning themselves right saying we're
horrible right and yeah you should do
your way go back to the native ways go
back to your your ancient ways exactly
wow it's amazing and we exported that
yeah we were going the complete opposite
way can that happen again do you think
uh you mean it seems like right now with
Trump there's a resurrect a Revival
happening if you will of of people
saying no let's think about America
first let's become self-sufficient let's
focus on our own and get built so that
we can be a blessing again to other
nations since we're going that
trajectory do you think because right
now things are pretty radical the
relationship between the two is pretty
volatile is is it possible to go the
other way again it is possible because
believe it or not um you know in the
Muslim
world and I hate the fact that I'm
associated with this you know people
think that I I label all Muslims as evil
crazy and radicals they're not you know
a lot of the Muslims are just born into
the religion and you know okay they're
just part of it they don't even some of
them don't know what it is if something
better comes along and people in Mass
move yeah a lot of it could happen it's
not it's not inconceivable if it
happened before right why wouldn't it
happen again and you know so a lot of
Muslims themselves remember they're
often times the first victims of Islam
did did is has Islam gone through any
sort of um woke moments we've been
exporting a lot from usaid and other
things like that have we been able to
export any of our social justice stuff
any of our uh postmodernism is has
anything that we've tried to export to
Islam had any effect on it the only
thing I've seen is they exploit it which
means it's not that they believe any of
it but they'll use that language when
they're talking to the West uh they'll
talk about social justice so I remember
for example when I was translating
al-qaeda's writings
in the al-Qaeda reader the whole point
was to show you what they were writing
to each other in Arabic which was pure
radical Isis stuff and that's what I had
found in the library Congress and no one
knew about and then the other thing was
to talk about what they were writing to
the west and we knew about and what they
were writing to the West thank you yes
was um just the whole social justice
thing you know you they would actually
complain about because the you know the
US didn't sign the Kyoto Protocol about
the environment okay imagine Osama bin
Laden
so that's the only thing I've seen but I
don't think woke madness has to their
credit infiltrated Muslim lands yeah so
then they haven't had you know they
haven't been reformed in any way by this
new Western idea no that's interesting I
mean yeah amongst the the Muslims that
I'm talking about who are more
secularized maybe some of them but but
but Extreme wokeness I mean we're
talking about you know Insanity so right
no that's still a woman and she's
wearing a hijab okay well I I going to
say like I mean it seems like it's it's
it's ironic we've noticed that you have
these radical leftists who are all in on
all kinds of sexual deviancy
homosexuality whatever transgender stuff
and like but in traditional Islam
societies like you don't um like you
don't get away with that I mean mean you
know you see the videos of people
getting pushed off buildings and stuff
like that and you're saying like so and
they're the same ones doing the
Palestinian protests right yeah yeah you
know I mean you know way was like I
don't know that they you want them
cuz like I mean they're going to push
you off a building if they if they
actually get in control if they get in
control here right yeah because they're
idiots and uh you know you're talking
about the leftists who are like yeah of
course they don't they just yeah that
mality affects them um but the Muslims
would use it just they would exploit it
for their own so they don't mind
exploiting it to get a foothold in
universities and get people uh warming
up to Islam Islam is elastic enough to
work with infidels and homosexuals and
whatever as long as the end result
benefits
Islam power we're going to establish
Sharia it's interesting like right just
I'm sorry to cut you off to go with what
you're saying um there's this there's
this city I think in um Minish Michigan
or Minnesota hamran okay Dearborn are
you talking about well no I know
Dearborn it's but hamran it's got a
weird name hamran or something anyway um
apparently it's like more than 50% the
city council is Muslim majority okay
maybe the city itself is Muslim it's
like maybe 50% or more okay and uh there
was this big Fallout because once the
city council came into power and became
Muslim they banned all gay stuff yeah
and all the homosexuals got so upset say
we supported you we supported you we
wanted you we voted for you and now you
betrayed us
surprise thank you very much we'll take
it from here guess what's coming next